it does feel as if all of the numbers
right now
when it comes to kv-19 seem to be moving
in the wrong
direction how alarming should
is this i think it's so important that
the detection systems that's been set up
in the uk
have picked up this signal that we're
seeing a really sharp rise in cases
and it's come from several sources i
think
everyone is in agreement that we really
need to act very quickly now
in order to prevent this from growing
exponentially
i think that's the main point is that we
must act fast
because it's so much harder to get this
sort of thing under control if you delay
even a few days is potentially going to
be quite dangerous
now at this particular moment
interesting to say that even a few days
of delay
uh could be uh critical so mark walpole
the former
chief scientific advisor said that
britain is on the edge of losing control
of covid do you think he's right
well yes i think that is right it's it's
a bit like
water seeping through a dam you know it
starts as a trickle
and if you don't do something about it
then it can turn into a
real sort of cascade um and we know from
for example the react study which is uh
being run by
paul elliott and uh steve riley that the
reproduction number has now jumped you
know it was down at about 0.5
at its best during the summer it's now
so that's 1.7 people for every person
who's infected
and that means exponential growth
and there's a story which has been
leaked into the sunday times today
showing that it's back in old in care
homes as well
so you know we know that these are very
vulnerable
pockets it's not just in the younger
people it's it's starting to appear
in in people more vulnerable and that
in inevitably is going to be followed by
hospital admissions and deaths
so you know we need to act quickly and
this isn't the game you know we
shouldn't be out
trying to party as hard as we can in the
run-up to monday's lockdown we should
all be
really thinking about what we can do now
to uh to slow down the spread
um talking about what we can do to slow
down the spread of course from
monday we'll see these new rules coming
in the rule of six you can't meet more
than
uh six people at any time inside or
outside
do you think that we need to look at
further restrictions
perhaps it's encouraging people to work
from home again perhaps it's curfews
what do you think it's really difficult
to
get the rules sensible and straight and
and easy to understand and i can quite
see why the government wants to
bring in something which is very simple
and straightforward i mean the rule of
six is based on some statistical
modeling so it's not just arbitrary they
haven't picked the number
out of out of thin air um but it does
seem
somewhat irrational in some of the
detail and i
can appreciate that but i'm afraid
you know it's going to cause pain and
suffering for us all
to go back to some degree of lockdown
but if we don't do this now we're going
to be right back in hard lockdown
in short order that's the only way we
have at the moment for controlling this
but there are other things on the
horizon i think that's really
encouraging we just need to
slow it down and delay it and wait for
um for vaccines and for better
treatments
just to pick up on something you said
that what do you think is irrational
about the government's policy then
well i think people have been you know
complaining widely about
the um you know the fact that you can
carry on doing things like um
exercising in groups and uh doing sports
and uh
getting together for special events but
yet you can't have
um you can't have both a grandmother and
a grandfather come to visit your home if
you're a
family of five so it you know it is
inevitably going to
create those um those difficulties which
are hard to explain in terms of
of irrational advice but it is on the
other hand very simple
and i think simplicity is so important
we've had some rather complicated rules
which be very hard to interpret and not
backed up
actually by legal enforcement so this is
this is different now it is legally
enforceable
and it's very simple yeah certainly
there's a positives
when it comes from a simple message um
we've got a growing number of cases
schools have only just gone back
the weather of course is yet to get
really cold
and yet we've also got many many young
people returning to
universities which will be kind of
levels of mass migration if you like
internal
eternal to the country with people
moving around different parts of the
united kingdom
how concerned are you about the impact
of universities
on case numbers well i think
universities have gone to great lengths
to try to make
the return to university as safe as it
possibly can be
we know that the major transmission is
likely to be in
social settings you know in halls of
residence with pressures drinking events
and so on
and those are definitely the times when
transmission is likely to
occur i mean you know many universities
including my own have put in
a lot of measures to try to mitigate
this
and i think we we can do it safely um
we are going to do it as safely as we
possibly can we're going to find cases
as quickly as we can
and try to ensure the safety of both
staff and students
i think there's been a huge effort put
into this and i do think that
that it is right to go back to school
back to university
but with all these safety measures of
course
uh the thing that many people are
holding out for when it comes to
any kind of return to normality is a
vaccine
how far off do you think we are well i
was a bit pessimistic a few months ago
but i think with all the vaccine trials
which are now coming through
um which are scheduled to deliver a
result within the next few months
i i do feel that on the basis of what we
know about the immune system
that it's likely that these immune
responses which are being
induced by these vaccines may be
protective at least for
a few months possibly even years we just
don't know yet it's early days
but um it's i think i do think that we
will probably have positive results of
at least one of these vaccine trials
probably more than that by christmas and
that means that
with rapid scaling up we might have
vaccination programs which can roll out
to some parts of the world um over the
next
nine months so before the winter of
2021-22 i hope that we should have
vaccines
which are effective the problem is going
to be reaching the parts of the world
where
these vaccines might have maximal impact
um
where the resources are that are low and
medical care is
is hard to access i think it's it's
going to be a
good solution for those of us who can
get the vaccines but it won't be a
global solution